hey everybody it's me um yeah just
haven't made a video in a while it's
been a just to be honest with my patreon
followers it's been a rough couple weeks
but also amazing and full of great
experiences meet new friends at
Fahrenheit and fire drums and performing
a bunch of times with uh seven textur
been great and just been a lot of stuff
going I put my cat down it's kind of sad
it's not that bad but
uh want to get you started on some
tutorials for today so check it out
first tutorial I'm going to record a few
today possible is with a
boang have my supers on the way soon
this one's for Don Purdue just he's not
coming to stick out but which is a small
Retreat that I'm running um so check it
out first technique I learned from J
firat um you're going to hold B gang in
front of you and it's going to go under
your arm and over your head you can
see finger spinning the B
gang just kind of see under the arm over
the head Jam both
[Music]
directions and you can kind of treat it
like it's isolating this little
point if you want or you can kind of
have it rotate in place so that the bang
handle moves in a little circle that way
I find to be the
easiest and you jam that with both
hands so I find it easier in the eye
hand to tip configuration but in
together here I am going around my head
it's kind of neat too because it makes a
shape
there and there um can also go the other
way if you want be going back and forth
you can do it in front of you without
going around your head but I think the
around the head giv some cool looks
you can kind of see this is together
Time same direction can also do this
rotation um in other timing directions
uh the easiest from this available would
be split opposite kind of looks like
[Music]
this fast
motion yeah so again basic technique
goes around my head and under my arm
around my head kind of harder with
bigger Bo gang but not too bad and you
get that and then yeah there's also a
couple variations that are fun if I hold
it horizontally that's also possible
kind of see around my head and under my
arm so and together that
way I like this one this one's cool
because it looks cooler isolated and
then the split opposite
[Music]
horizontal
yeah I hope that was a cool bugang trick
for you guys uh I learned from J firat
at bugang convergence
and kind of came up with the split
opposite but the basic technique is just
Under and Over the arm thanks for
watching and uh please tell your friends
about my patreon at this point I just
want to thank all of you that have been
here and uh yeah just much love to my
mom who new 25 bucks thanks
Mom